[Müzik]
İyi akşamlar Ben Meltem Karaoğlu Hem
öyle seviyesiyim hem Aynı zamanda da
çocuk yazarıyım ama aynı zamanda
çalışıyor Aslında Niye öğretemiyorlar
size onu anlatacağım size bu konuda
okullara gidiyorum Bir sürü eğitimlerde
veriyorum Ayrıca benim fuarlarda falan
kitap fuarları da bulurlar
Şimdi size hem benim aklımdan nasıl
çalışıyor Neden öyle öğrenmeye
sıkıntısı çekiyormuşuz gibi görünüyor
aslında hiç öyle bir şey yok size onu
anlatacağım disk yapımına başlayalım
isterseniz
söylediklerinizde bir sıkıntıyla
karşılaşıyoruz çünkü okul başlayana
kadar hepimiz güzel gözü oynuyoruz
harika Zaman geçiriyoruz öyküler
yazıyoruz ailemizin
hiç ilgili bir şeyi yok
sorunu yok çünkü oynayan Gülen biraz
yaratıcı yaramaz çocuklarım
Fakat benim gibi olursanız yani
desteksiz ki 2000'den önce bu 10 kişiden
biri de fakat günümüzde 5 kişidendir
yani öyle düşünürsek her sınıfta bayağı
bir iki tane falan çocuk olması
gerekiyor
sizin de disleksiniz olabilir Ve bunun
farkına varmamış olabilirsiniz Çünkü
daha önce benim yaşlarımızda Bize hala
işte biraz yavaş çalışalım yaramaz gibi
dikkat etmeyen
iyice okuduğunu anlayamayan çocuklar
olarak görüyorlardı ama aslında tam
tersine gördüğünüz gibi yani Gayet
yerlere gelebiliyoruz
kaldık birçok ünlü eksik insanlar var
biliyorsunuz internetten bakarsınız
şimdi bizim düşündüğümüz zaman
her kişinin farklı bir çiçek olduğunu
artık biliyoruz Demek ki sistemimiz asla
bakarsanız bütün dünyadaki sistem Eğer
ki herkesle formatif olarak aynı gruba
alıyorsa aynı sistemin içerisine
eğitmeye çalışıyorsa Aslında çok
başarılı da olmuyor demektir çünkü
filmlerde çok farklı
şeyler ilgi alanları olan insanlarız
aslına bakar
sınız bilmiyorum
çok aynı zamanda
ikinci biraz da böyle şeydir
narin bir psikolojik yapıya sahipti O
yüzden de ona ben Orkide gibi davranırım
eğitim alırken de aynı şekilde kendisi
Eee bu şekilde Narin ince
Detaylara bakarak
şey yapar öğrenir o yüzden de onun şeyi
Birazcık böyle Eee iki tane buz koyup
içerisinde güzel güzel eğitim almak ya
da yaşamak ya da beslenmektir
Eşim Osman
[Müzik]
bilmeyen bir çiçek kaçıyor kafamda
ve dikeceğimizi bilemiyoruz ve aç
kaldığında da olan bu oluyor
Maalesef benim gibi insanlar Ee küçükken
kendilerini anlatamadıklarında
başarısız olduğunda ve biraz daha çalış
çocuğum dendiğinde
Biliyorum ve yani cam kırıyordum
konuştularımı kırıyordum Babam da
Rüyamda dedi paralarını verdiği zaman
müthiş böyle bir saç kesim hissediyordum
ay Yaşasın işte beni anlıyorlar burada
ilişkisi de Öfken bir yere git diye Bu
arada cezaevindeki bir araştırmaya göre
cezaevindeki yüzde yüzde 60 kalan kişi
listesi ve kendisi ifade edemiyor
Anlaşılan bir okulda başarısız
görülmüşler ya da aileleri ya da
çevreleri tarafından biraz yavaş gitmiş
işte öğrenemiyormuş gibi hisset
bizim İlknur
Analitik bir kafada bilgiye ulaşmak için
veri tabanına gider doğru şeyi bulur
kitabı bulur ya da bilgiyi bul
ur her şeyi alır ona göre bir analiz
yapar
dosyaları var Dosya şeyini açıyor
çekmecesini açıyor turşu çekme
sitesinden doğru dosyayı içinden doğru
şeyi buluyor dokümanı
buluyor istediğin yapıyor ona gelince
ben başka biri geldi
bir sporta bir şey söylemem gerekiyor
Ben şey şey demeye başladığımda Biraz
sonra göreceksiniz ki bir politik
topluma soran varist eksik olarak yani
beynimde bazı sözcükleri
burada görsel onlar
o sırada kadar şeyle idare ediyorum sizi
geçiştiriyorum yani o arada Biraz sonra
anlatacağım
bana bir soru sordun
soru sorduğunuzda Biraz önceki Hani o
dosyalar
çekmeceler vardı ya ben de öyle
işlemiyor benim bir yılbaşı ağacım var
amediye paketi var
hediye paketleri
içerisinde soruyor Ben böyle kafama göre
en parmağını en güzelini seçiyorum
paketlerden içinden ne çıkarsa
Hiç büyümünden ya da benim aradığım şey
çıkıyor o Elimde bir şeyden
bir şey anlatıyorsunuz arkadaş
toplantısındayım muhabbet muhabbet Ama
orada ben sizi
dedim hikaye yazıyorum size
bisikletle atmış dağlara çıkıyorum
şeyler de deniz kenarlarında küçükken
bir şey yaşamışım o geliyor aklıma Oo o
sırada Kendisi diyor kendime geliyor
mesela ya sınıfta ise o arada dikkat
eksikliği ortaya çıkıyor annemi
çağırıyorlar dikkat eksikliği var
çocuğunuzun diyorlar mesela
her geçiyor kendime geliyorum
tekrarlanıyor bana bir soru sormuşlardı
diyorum sınavda iyi mesela
gidiyorum soruyu tekrardan ele alıyorum
Bir paket daha açıyorum içinden kardan
adam çıkıyor Bir de bisiklet çıkmıştı
erikte hikaye yazıyorum Bu sefer kardan
adamı bisiklete bindiriyorum uçuruyorum
kaçırıyorum aklıma ilki filmi geliyor
ayın üstünden önünden uçuyor ediyor
sonra şey geliyor
bir daha geliyor aklıma şey bu böyle
sürüyor Bu arada
filmler sürüyor ve ondan sonracığıma bir
süper kahraman geliyor Dur diyor o
sırada da müdahada
uzatıyorum
detaylandırıyorum kapımın içerisinde
sınav gidiyor sizin muhabbetleriniz
gidiyor uzuyor ama ben hala buradayım Ve
sonra tekrar Ben sana böyle bir sinyal
veriyor Diyor ki Ama sen sınavda
muhabbet içerisinde ne yapacaksın Aa bir
dakika diyorum doğru şeyi bulduğumda
kutuyu açtığımda doğru cevabını
bilmiyorsan Bir de yapamıyorum biraz
zaman kaybetmiş oluyorum
ki İlknur'la
akıllı normal olarak düşündüğü
insanlarla Aynı sınıftaysan ben ailesini
yapıyorsan
onlar 10 sorudayken Ben ancak 1 soruda
oluyorum ondan
[Müzik]
sonra şimdi
bilgiye nasıl ulaşıyoruz
sistemin kendi şeyleri var
akıllı ya da normal diye bir söylediği
insanlar var İlknur bunlardan biriydi
İlknur bilgiye gayet güzel bir şekilde
yol kanadı veri tabanından Bilgi çıkıyor
sınavda ise ya da büyük konuşmada ise
sorulup soruluyorsa hemen bunun cevabını
kısa sürede veriyor Bunun nedeni
Siz normal diye düşünüldüğü veya koyduğu
ortaya koyduğu insanların
hepsi onların Belki bir Ee mesafede
O yüzden çok iyi iletişim kurabiliyoruz
birbirimize aynı bilgiyi aynı şekilde
öğrenebiliyoruz ama otistik bireylerde
mesela
Bunlar şeyde bir yere odaklanıyor oradan
çıkmanın zorlaşıyor aynı şeyde Ee
Osman'a baktığımızda Osman da böyle
olacak çünkü
kolay şekilde sonuca ulaşmak
isteyince yöntemi belirleyecek
tir ve hemen oraya ulaşacağım ama
Ben bir denizden çok ayrı Bu da ne demek
bir Galaksi yerine birkaç Galaksi var
içerisinde yani Ben yalnızca yaptığım
işle değil dışarıda ağaçtaki kuşlarla
komşu ne diyor annem içeride Ne yapıyor
Ben neymiştim dün akşam Ondan sonra aa
ben hiçbir şekilde konsantrasyon
olamayabilirim çünkü
bunlar hepsi aynı yerde dolanıyor bilg
inin zaman alıyor istasyon
ları çok Aralık var başka istasyonları
da kapıyorum sinyal olarak
aylarsınız
geçiyor ben burada yaratıcılık alıyorum
pek çok şeyden beslenebilecek hale
geliyorum Bu nedenle de bizden çok
yaratıcı bazı olayları bir
sürü büyük resmi gören kişiler çıkıyor
sınavdayız böyle bir durumda
ve
Duman çok başarılı olacaklar ama
balık sınav zamanında Eğer ki
Candan dışarıya baktıysan
şu yuvada ister Yumurtaları da varsa
Olay bitti orada ben orduları Onlar
hakkında bayağı bir öykü yazarım oraya
baka kalırım bunu öykülendirdiğim için
başkasını anlatmak isterim önümde sıra
vardır öğretmen falan yapar Ben soruya
bakarım Aklımda hala o arada bir
ambulans geçer
im falan derken
Terim sınavı Ben bitiremem sınavı ve
ondan sonra zaman bitince kendimi de çok
kötü hissetmedim zaten hiç bir
konserasyonunda kalmamıştı Bu şekilde
bir hata veriyor dedim ve kolay orada
tekrardan
[Müzik]
Hayat böyle geçer mi diye
düşündüm Bazı şeylerin için
yaş grupları için ve bazı yerlerde
yaşayan insanların için geçiyor çünkü
herkes disleksi ne olduğunu bilmiyor ve
de çocuklara ilaç vermekle ya da
psikoloğa gitmekle yetinenler de var
korkulacaklı çalışıyor
lar O yüzden Bizden çok iyi stratejist
olur Bizden çok iyi şey olur film
yaparız yazar oluruz ve anneniz sizi
çıkardınız Ben çok iyi ya da gerçekten
iyi
bir şey
tamarsa Biz de alabilirsiniz Çünkü biz
hiç görmediğiniz şeyleri detayları
ayrıntıları görürüz
Rabbim
bu da ne demek
karışabilir
Üçler Eller karışabilir matematik
0 O yüzden bir mühendisle evlendim
oradan konuşuyoruz matematik
şimdi kutuya geçiyorum Tabii sistem
içerisinde ve
öğretmen çaresiz kalıyor okul çaresiz
kalıyor anne baba çaresiz kalıyor
Hatta nöroloğa gidiyorsunuz başka bir
şey düşün
üp başka bir şey
düşünüyor anlamıyorlar
ne şimdi
evine kadar
Bir de da vinci'ler falan hep pislikse
Ya sen niye böyle
uçurdun mu işte yapılır mı kanat mı
yapıyorsun Ne yapıyorsun diye bir
söylemedi ya da YouTube'a sormadı Bunun
nedeni Sanayi devrim
inde Ee
bu Ee şeyi bulduk bulmasından sonra ama
akvaryum olmasından sonra her şeyi
yazıya da dökülmesi ile ve de Ee bir
sistematik eğitim olmasından sonra
sisteme yönelik kişi yetiştirilmek
isteyen Bence sistemi uyamadığımdan
belli sistem dışı bırakarak benim gibi
insanlara cidden düşün bırakarak
Sanayi yani modern Dünya'ya bireyler
yetiştirilen eğitim sisteminde ona
yönelik insanlar belirlendi bu insanlar
akıllı ve de aynı zamanda
normal olarak düşünüldün Ama benim
gibi Eskiden maalesef
uzaylı yaptı Ben bu sistemi uygun
değilim şimdi bu durumda
başarabiliyorsak
şeyimiz var örneğimiz var
başarabiliyorsak Eğer o zaman ben mi
Öyle De Güzel mi bana öğretemiyor burada
herkesin böyle şapkasını önüne alıp
düşünmesi gerekiyor
ben
Doktorum bu sistemde ben yapamıyorum Ne
yapmam gerekiyor nedir benim sorunum
soru var diyor sistem bana E yani Nedir
o diyorum
değil onunla onlar olsun diye bana
anlatıyor ne olduğunu şimdi ben bu
konuda kitap yazdım pek çok yerde de
okutuluyor şimdi
bunu aslında
nasıl öğrendiğini nasıl
görürsün Nur akıllı arkadaşım diyelim
yalnızca harflerle geliyor öyle bir Bey
yapısı var
görmüyorum ben resmi olarak görüyorum
her şeyi resim olarak gördüğüm için de
bu ne demek
bir ağ yalnız arasın o terste döner
yapıştığı yere de koyarım onu
yapışmadığı yere de koyarım Hadi atalım
nasıl isterse bazen de eğer ki
Aralık ekoyarım He yaparım ya da daha
güzel görünür ama sözcük değişir
bana öğretirken farklı
yön Bu da ne demek Eğer siz bana okulda
ayakkabıyı böyle şişlerle öğretirseniz
ben Ölemem ezberliyorum zaten o da
herkesten
IBAN alıyor ezberleme O nedenle de bana
siz ayakkabıyı yazarsanız ben onu tren
diye de o krom araba değil de okurum
bana eğer
ki bir şey değil görselleriyle birlikte
koymanız gerekiyor ve bir süre sonra
görselleri çıkardığınızda Ben zaten
sözcüğü ezberleyeceğim için çok daha
kolay döverim ama bunu
Şimdi ben dedim ki sözcükleri
ezberliyorum sözcük
Eğer ezberleme bir sözcük
bir şey geliyorsa Eğer
ki bir umuyorum
gibi bir cümleyi
okuduğunda bunu
da sınav ve liseye giriş sınavı
Üniversiteye giriş sınavı zaten hiç
şansım yok
olmuş oluyor
böyle bir durumda karşılaştığımda Tabii
hangi yaşta olursanız olun cam kırma
şeyine
giriyorsunuz Mesela ben bütün bir
sayfayı bir resim olarak görüyorum
Dünde de
onun hepsini okumam mümkün değil hani
böyle sınavlarda böyle böyle paragraflar
veriyorlar
benim için hiçbir anlamı yok çünkü
dese geliyorum
[Müzik]
ama
ilk baktığımda şunu görüyorum bildiğin
sözcükler çak çak çak çak çak çıkıyor
içerisinden
oradakinden çok farklı bir şey çıkıyor
ortaya
ışıklarda yoksa bulamıyorum zaten ondan
sonra of yapıyorum
ya da yani bir şey varsa ki tamamen
buradakinden çok farklı bir şey onu
işaretliyorum ondan sonra zaten sınavdan
Geçemiyorum anne
babaya gidiyor Ne yapacağız biz bu
çocukla diye
böyle parçalar veriliyorsa okumam için
yine 3 bizli zaman verilmesi gerekiyor
doğru mu
Eğer ki onunla nasıl başa çıkacağınızı
bilmiyorsanız size rehberlik edecek hiç
kimse yoksa
anlaşamıyorsa sizde yalnızca ilaçla
yiyorsa ve de aşağıya doğru çek
iyorsun konsantrasyonunuzu dikiş olarak
böyle yavaşlatıyorsa Duygu durumunuzu
etkiliyorsa
zor limon oluyor Ama eğer ki
eğer ki limonata yapmayı öğren
irsin yani ne de başarılısınız her şeye
başarılı olmak zorunda değilsiniz Ama
disleksiler birden fazla şeyde dahi
olabilirler ama
yarışını
bir gerekir O
seti kendisine olan güvenini
kaybetmemesi gerekir ya da sürekli
Çocuğum çok çalış diye Herkes böyle
yapıyor sen yapamıyorsun gibi şeylerle
karşılaşınca yine de böyle
olur Ve siz Eğer keşfetmezseniz niyetine
de çok iyi maalesef kaybet
ebilir çocukluktaki yeteneği
şanslı
45 bütün dünyada
%1 alanında diske eksilen şanslı bir
yere
gelemeyiz tabi yasalar burada kaç
disneyse bu şansı acaba
bu şekilde
bir değerle
bunu yapabilmemiz için de bizim Eee kısa
laflarımızı daha renkli hale getirmemiz
destekçim çocuklarla görüştüğümüz zaman
veya onlara eğitim vereceğimiz zaman
dediğim gibi çoklu bilgiyi vermemiz
lazım yani siz bana inci küpeli kızı
anlatıyorsanız bunun Kim yapmış ne zaman
yapılmış işte Bunun filmini de söylet
diyeceksiniz ansiklopedik bilgiyi de
vereceksiniz bana çizgi film varsa her
şeyin seyrettirmeniz gerekiyor ki Ben
öğrenebilirim ama yalçın kitabı
5 molada beni kaybedersiniz aynı şekilde
bu fişleri ta okula başladığımız zaman
sözcükleri bize öğretebilirseniz evi
desteklerseniz çok başarılı yerlere
gelebiliyor bizde
arkadaşım var örnek olarak
ben de kendimce
havadan buralara geldim Ancak şöyle bir
durum var o kadar yazılmışım ki aileleri
doç
[Müzik]
ento
olacak galiba dedim o kadar benden şey
yapmışlar
bir zaman içerisinde
biz nasıl düşünüyoruz
anlatabilmişimdir İyi akşamlar diliyorum
[Alkış]
[Müzik]